the jurogan experience the biggest issue
by far over this past year has been the
homeless crisis right that's the biggest
thing is the
increase in the tents and the chaos and
you know when uh
dave chappelle and i were doing stubs
we'd go down 8th street and there's that
underpass and it was just like a village
down there it was crazy
um what happened how did that all get
going
like what what was the motivation for
allowing people to camp in public places
well that's account that's the action
the council took two years ago but so
let's go
okay back before two years ago you know
when i came into office we had
an outdoor area that kind of looked like
you know what you have
downtown in skid row in l.a but ours was
just in a in a block
area but that's what everybody talked
about and you
where was that area it was uh over
toward i-35
toward the highway it was at the the
arch which was a
shelter but most of the people there
never went inside they kind of gathered
outside it was an open-air market
of all kinds of horrible things and
people wanted that to disappear the
problem with making that disappear
is that you this challenge is not one
you can just
make go away you can move it but but if
you
close it down anywhere it's going the
people don't disappear so they'll come
back
but that was a challenge coming into
office uh but
in my second third and fourth years in
office i started going to neighborhood
association meetings
and whereas in the past people would
want to talk about zoning or flooding
now all they wanted to talk about was
this homeless encampment that was near
them somewhere
in the woods in the stream somewhere
nearby
they were blaming the um the the petty
crime happening
in the neighborhood on them every one of
them had a wife or a daughter that had a
horrible experience related to them
and i was going to these neighborhood
association meetings and people were
as angry as i have ever seen at a public
meeting
demanding that something be done
uh i had one of them uh here a
neighborhood
a guy came up to me after it was over
and he said your mayor
fix this and if you don't i have a gun
and i will fix this myself
jesus and and i don't know that he
actually meant that but but
there was that was the fervor and the
feel
and i had as as a member of this city
council
nothing to offer that neighborhood
association
they were complaining about people that
were under an overpass at uh
the the highway not too far away from
them
and i knew that if we fenced in that
overpass which of course we couldn't do
because it's not city property it's
state property but if the state
fenced it in so that those people
weren't there anymore
uh they don't disappear so all they're
going to do is
is move up the highway or down the
highway
or somewhere else and i was going to
more and more neighborhood associations
that were complaining more and more
about encampments
and and i had no solution
to that and what hurt was is we knew
what worked
so in that same period of time we said
let's house every vet in our city
that's experiencing homelessness you
know there was a national program doing
it a lot of cities participated austin
was one of a handful of cities to
successfully get that done
community came together we we
when you take someone who's experiencing
homelessness and you put them
into a home and get them wrapped around
services
there's like a 90 95 success rate
that that person will either reintegrate
back into society or will
sustain themselves in a in a positive
way
wherever it is 90 95 and it seems like
austin
being a fairly small city you're dealing
with a much smaller
even though it's a large number of
people per se
it's it's it's it's almost a manageable
number like you might be able to do that
with all these homeless people
whereas if you're in a place like los
angeles and dealing with a hundred
thousand people
like what's the number of homeless
people in austin right you are
you're dead on and and quite frankly
that's the
the the gamble or the the what the city
council was trying to do two years ago
so on our streets on any given night
there's about three thousand people that
are experiencing homelessness
la city almost fifty thousand it's i
think
you know but it's it's increased to the
point it's hard to
say whether or not it's increased or its
exposures increase because they've all
moved to like venice beach where there's
just thousands of tenants the numbers
are going up yeah you know and in
seattle
san francisco smaller cities than austin
have three to
six times as many people experiencing
homelessness
you know i was with the mayor in l.a and
i
and i said to him i said god i don't
even know what you do
i mean the scale of your challenge is so
great the cost to actually
turn this around i said i i don't know
what you do
and i said so i'm not here asking you
what you do but i'm asking you what do
you wish you had done
eight years ago ten years ago to prevent
being
where you are today what are you saying
he gave me the same answer
that the experts gave me in san
francisco and portland and seattle they
all said
if you hide this challenge it's going to
continue to grow
until it is so big you can't hide it
anymore but at that point it's going to
be too big for you to actually
meaningfully deal with it
they said it's it is like the political
issue
right now in in l.a and in san francisco
it's like
important they said i wish that we were
as resolved to fix it eight ten years
ago as we are today
because we would have been able to set
up the systems so that we could have
reached equilibrium and now we wouldn't
be here
you've got places like san francisco
that have such tolerant policies towards
homeless people that people gravitate to
san francisco to be homeless
which is really kind of crazy but true
people have actually moved there with
the intention
of like taking advantage of all their
services taking advantage of the food
and shelter
and the ability to do whatever you want
and you know you could actually get
money
from certain services in san francisco
there's like a fine line between helping
and encouraging people to continue the
lifestyle
and you know for some people the freedom
of just being able to camp
and do whatever you want there they're
checked out right
for whatever reason whether it's mental
illness whether it's just
they prefer this sort of vagabond
lifestyle
i don't know whatever what it is but
is there a like is there a line that you
have to
make sure you don't cross over where you
don't make it easier for them to be
homeless
you want to encourage them to take
advantage of these things you were
trying to set up where you're talking
about
providing them with wrap around services
where you can actually reintegrate them
to society
like how do you make that distinction
well you know
so much of the debate and the discussion
around homelessness
has turned so political
like so many other kinds of discussions
but but homelessness is one of the big
ones
so i have continued to ask the people
that are working daily with the universe
of people experiencing homelessness in
our city
about 10 thousand people in any given
year
intersect with our homelessness system
about three thousand people on any given
day
in our city experiencing homelessness
and i've asked that question
are we pulling people in and what they
tell me
consistently for the last six years
seven years
is that you can find anecdotally where
that has happened
but generally speaking the overwhelming
number of people
experiencing homelessness in our city
are people who fell into homelessness
here
the people that are coming into our city
most of them are coming from the areas
immediately around us
i had one of them tell me once that
there's not a a voter's guide
to cities for people experiencing
homelessness and
austin would be in danger going from two
stars to
three stars and people would start
coming we have enough
challenge getting people experiencing
homelessness to go from one side of the
city to the other side of the city once
they have a
of have a place so
where i'm looking at here and i know
that that the governor
you know gavin newsom in california
told people that uh that austin and
texas were
giving people tickets and sending people
to to california did he say that
he said that not true from i mean
no wait a minute that guy lied about
something that's crazy that's what i
hear
uh but the uh um
so so i'm i'm i'm just you know we we
just need to
handle it we need to get people we need
to get people off the streets so the
council did was
we said we made it work with veterans
and then i tried to scale up what we did
with veterans
but i couldn't get the the resolve to
spend the money
and part of the reason was is because
people didn't see the
challenge so there'd be some
neighborhoods that were willing to do it
i knew as as sure as the sun was going
to come up the next day that this was
now accelerating in our city
so what we said was we're going to
maintain the ordinances that say if you
threaten public safety or public health
you can get arrested and ticketed and
put in jail because that's important
somebody's doing that they should be
arrested and ticketed and put in jail
but if they're not doing that if all
they're doing
is surviving then it is
inhumane to either put that person in
jail
or to force that person to live down in
the streams and
in the woods because you you it's an
even
worse place for them to be so
why is it a worse place for them to be
camping in the woods than to be camping
on a public street
well in well one you don't want anybody
camping in a public street either
right so that's not a solution to the
challenge
you can't have that happen either but if
somebody is in the
woods or down by the streams they're not
interacting with anybody else
so you have you have hundreds of women
that are getting assaulted
every night as the price to be able to
live
in that environment because they're
they're secluded
and they're not safe so you mean if a
homeless woman
moves to the woods she's in danger
because there's no one around her
unless she's to a protector unless she
picks a protector
she's not in a community of homeless
people and so this is one of the reasons
why these people gravitate towards these
places like that eighth street underpass
because
there's a lot of them together and there
there's a sense of
and they can see it our health officials
can find them right we're now
vaccinating
our entire population of people
experiencing homelessness because we can
find them
the mistake that we made is that when we
did something that meant people were
going to come out of the woods and the
streams
we should have identified at that point
where people could go and not go
and we didn't do that we didn't we
didn't manage the public spaces the
shared spaces
the way that we should have so what the
council did that summer summers we said
okay we're going to decriminalize it
because
every person who you know in 19 in in
in 2016 thereabouts we wrote like 18 000
tickets
and as you imagine very few of those
people ended up in court the following
thursday to pay their
fine they end up bench warrant issues
for their arrest and then you can't get
they six months later they have trouble
getting a job or an apartment so now
they have a criminal record
right so they said we're just not going
to do that anymore
but on the same day we did that we asked
the city manager to come back with a set
of rules that would say
okay so we we where is it that people
can go and
can't go uh and
for lots of reasons that never happened
and that's where we made our mistake
so if you could go back and do it all
over again
from the moment you got into office what
would you have done differently
well the the what we did initially
uh in terms of with the veterans was
real successful i would do that again it
proves up the model
can you explain how how that works like
what what what did you do exactly for
the veterans
well veterans are a little bit easier
because they come with resources so they
come with what are called vash vouchers
from the federal government
which is support to help do rent
supplements
but then it was reaching out to
everybody in the city
that had apartment buildings big
managers of apartment buildings with
these vouchers and we would say would
you take in
these vets and and and people were
willing to do that
um we had some landlords that were
suspicious of and say i'm not going to
do this because if i take someone like
this they're going to trash out the
place and
that'd be six months to evict them so i
got together with some private
businesses in the lake we created a risk
fund outside of city government
and we put it into the community
foundation and we said if you take a
tenant
and they trash out your place or create
a problem you call in the morning you
get a check in the afternoon
all the landlords said they don't
believe me because it's city it's going
to take you
five months i said it's not in the city
it's privately funded we're doing it
outside the city
that's a great solution it was great and
it took trusting
the landlord that they weren't going to
be making claims unless they actually
had problems
so you start with this you take the
veterans
you have this these vouchers you bring
them into apartment buildings you get
them places
that's step one so now they have a roof
over their head but how do you
help them clean up the service providers
in the city
all said because we all got everybody
together and we said let's let's let's
get
to equilibrium with veterans which means
that
i mean you can never end homelessness
but what you can do is get to a place
where the rate at which you house people
and they come out of housing back to
life is the same rate at which they show
up experiencing homelessness
i said let's do that with veterans it
was part again of a federal program what
percentage of the homeless folks are
veterans
you know i think it's probably right now
about six
percent something like that the number
was higher back then
because we had more veterans on the on
the on the streets
but the service providers all came in
and said okay if you can house vets
you can find places for them we'll start
prioritizing them
for giving them services catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience